12 1612 ce qu'est exactement en france
pour 450 décès principal foyer le grand
test l'hôpital militaire de campagne à
mulhouse prend forme
il devrait être effectif en milieu de
semaine prochaine six des seize camions
du convoi sont arrivés ce matin et un
deuxième avion a été affrété par l'armée
afin d'évacuer des malades vers bordeaux
six patients doivent arriver cet après
midi au chu de la capitale de la gironde
objectif désengorger les services de
réanimation saturé écoutez cette
infirmière qui lance un appel au secours
je pense que la situation fait qu'il
faut dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont pour faire prendre conscience à la
population de la gravité de l'enjeu
on ne peut plus cacher les choses là
c'est
on est dépassé moi j'ai peur j'ai peur
pour moi j'ai peur pour mes proches je
fais du mal à avoir l'issue en fait on a
des patients très jeune très jeune sans
problèmes de santis qui
qui sont en réanimation donc ça touche
tous les âges sans problème de santé
particulier
du coup on est amené à devoir faire des
choix on ne peut plus proposer tous les
soins tous les patients on doit choisir
qui a le plus de chances du coup de se
rétablir par la suite c'est difficile
pour nous c'est difficile de se dire
qu'on tourne pas tout pour chacun on a
du coup dû mal du mal à tenir notre
poste on a du mal à regarder dans les
yeux nos patients je pense qu'il
faudrait vraiment un confinement
drastiques que les gens restent chez eux
avec ce soit vraiment appliquée